[Música]
les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de France 24 en este primer
programa del 2023 nos enfocamos en El
séptimo arte Empezando por la ceremonia
de los Globos de oro que abrió la
temporada de los festivales y de los
premios de cine después de dos años de
escándalos por racismo sexismo y
corrupción y tras habérsele negado una
ceremonia televisiva el año pasado los
globos de oro regresaron en Los Ángeles
y del lado del cine los grandes
ganadores de esta edición número 80 son
la tragicomedia irlandesa los Espíritus
de La Isla con tres premios y el
director estadounidense Steven spielberg
se fue con las estatuillas a mejor
película dramática y mejor director para
los favelman una cinta dramática muy
íntima inspirada en su propia juventud
lo interesante de los globos es también
que premia a la vez a las películas y
series dramáticas y a las obras de
comedia o musicales hacia Austin Butler
Kate blanchet Colin Father y Michelle
fueron galardonados como mejores actores
y actrices el premio Y el discurso de
michelleo se destacaron en esta
ceremonia su papel en la enérgica y
sorprendente película independiente todo
en todas partes al mismo tiempo
convenció tanto a la crítica como al
público la escuchamos
Mírame llevo 40 años en el negocio y por
fin soy la número uno en la lista de
llamadas creo que esto simplemente
demuestra que si crees en ti mismo crees
Si sientes Pasión por lo que haces No te
rindes
creo que los tiempos están cambiando hay
mucha más inclusión hay más diversidad y
ya no es palabrería Cualquiera que fuera
el techo de cristal lo hemos derribado
de una patada Ninja ya lo hemos hecho
añicos y tenemos que mantenerlo así
del lado de los artistas latinos
Guillermo del Toro se fue con la
estatuilla a mejor película de animación
por su versión del cuento Pinocho en
stop motion está meticulosa técnica de
animación foto a foto a partir de
modelos y objetos que alguien mueve el
director mexicano compartió su felicidad
en el escenario
ha sido un gran año para el cine un cine
de todos los tamaños ambiciones grandes
vaivenes intimista y por lo tanto ha
sido un gran año para la animación
porque la animación es cine la animación
no es un género para niños es un medio
finalmente después de ser campeones del
mundo los argentinos ganaron el globo de
oro a mejor película de habla no inglesa
con la cinta Argentina
protagonizada por Ricardo darina y
dirigida por Santiago mitre con esta
estatuilla el drama histórico basado en
la historia real del juicio a los
militares por sus crímenes durante la
dictadura se posicionó sin duda en la
antesala de las nominaciones a los
premios Oscar miramos el tráiler
señor presidente es si mi hija está viva
o muerta
lentamente como para que no nos diéramos
cuenta una máquina de horror fue
Desatando su iniquidad sobre los
desprevenidos y los inocentes
vamos a hablar ahora de una película que
está en el punto de mira en Francia o
tiradores del director
estos tiradores son los más de 200.000
soldados de África subsahariana
reclutados a la fuerza o listados en las
ocho colonias que tenía Francia en la
época para luchar en los frentes de la
Primera Guerra Mundial más de 30.000 de
ellos perdieron la vida una dolorosa
página del pasado francés que fue
llevada a la pantalla a través de la
historia ficcional de un joven senegales
y de su padre que se alista
voluntariamente para cuidar de él en el
infierno de las trincheras en Francia
escuchamos a su actor principal o Maxi
explicar por qué está tan importante
contar esta historia
creo que hoy las generaciones que son
las nuestras las de ahora Necesitamos
esta historia para nuestra construcción
de hecho para aprender más sobre cómo
nos construimos en relación con estos
dos países tenemos un pie en cada uno y
para nuestra construcción este relato es
importante
[Música]
cerramos Este programa con otra película
que trata de una familia y de una guerra
que La amenaza la muy esperada Avatar el
sentido del agua tres años después las
criaturas azules de la saga ecológica
del estadounidense James Cameron están
de vuelta en una hora que impresionaba
por sus efectos especiales y su
tecnología esta segunda película es una
experiencia visual y cinematográfica que
está batiendo récord más de 1700
millones de dólares en la taquilla
mundial una obra única tanto para sus
fans como para sus actores
James Cameron siempre te lleva a través
de los viajes de la realidad de la vida
y las consecuencias cuando las
decisiones que se toman no son tan
sabias Avatar no es una excepción Pero
hay mucha esperanza va a haber mucho
crecimiento en este sentido y por eso
siento que esta continuación de la saga
de Avatar el sentido del agua va a ser
una experiencia totalmente nueva va a
ser casi como una nueva experiencia para
los viejos y los nuevos fans será la
introducción a una historia que una vez
más será inolvidable Nos despedimos con
el tráiler de Avatar el sentido del agua
Gracias a ustedes por su confianza y
sigan con nosotros hay más cultura en 24
y 24 punto com
[Música]